[Musique]
trois fois plus débordés que la
secrétaire normal la secrétaire
trilingue est d'un abord volontiers
revêche je suis d'abord volontiers
revêche pour lui redonner ce bon sourire
de dinde eurocratique si indispensable
au bon moral des prix chef de service il
serait tout à fait sobre venu
d'augmenter son salaire le plus simple
est de pratiquer sur elle le bouzouc
vous y part à l'habitude l'air
regardez bien
[Musique]
on la vache pied au foot en poupe et des
baux c'est tony chi ling note étonnant
tonneaux etonnant non
[Musique]
de très nombreuses personnes s'imaginent
que pour voir apparaître la sainte
vierge
il suffit de ramasser du bois mort dans
les pyrénées-orientales en enjambant les
ruisseaux c'est fou pour être sûr de
bien voir apparaître la vraie sainte
vierge
il faut de surcroît être une humble
bergère regardez bien
[Musique]
ah bah oui mais quand on n'est pas une
vraie bergère faut pas s'attendre à voir
apparaître une vraie vierge
voilà etonnant non
[Musique]
dans le peloton cliquetant des ordures
galonnés qui ont fait trembler le monde
sous la terreur infernal de leur
tyrannie hystérique adolf hitler vient
largement en tête parade un être aussi
abject est il capable du moindre
sentiment humain est bien pour le savoir
il nous suffit de suivre l'immonde
tirant dans sa promenade matinale
regardez bien bonjour madame rochât
bonjour monsieur le grumier
de nos jours les gens ne respectent plus
rien eh bien oui
hitler était capable d'un sentiment
humain il souffrait quand on lui disait
pas bonjour
non non
[Musique]
est on passé
grâce à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse la femme moderne peut
désormais sortir la tête haute et le
ventre plat mais un nouveau pas vers
l'humanisation de la médecine peut
encore être franchies
je veux parler non plus de l' ivg mais
deux lives et l'interruption volontaire
de vieillesse voyez ce septuagénaire de
70 ans je m'emmerde
qu'attendent-ils encore de la vie rien
du tout notre devoir
n'est-il point de pratiquer sur l'huile
iv v afin d'abréger son ennui
si bien sûr à une seule condition que
l'intéressé lui même donne son accord
alors monsieur vous êtes d'accord pour
que nous pratiquions sur vous
l'interruption volontaire de vieillesse
allons témoin cette seconde merci de
toute façon à cet âge là ils servent
plus qu'ils disent
etonnant non
[Musique]
l'homme moderne se doit de fustiger avec
véhémence toutes les formes de racisme
après tout les gens de couleurs ne sont
ils pas des gens comme nous comme vous
malheureusement il est extrêmement
difficile de prévoir une émeutes
raciales
c'est pourquoi il vaut mieux attendre
que les émeutes raciales et commencer
afin de pouvoir la mater grâce à cette
ultime rempart de la civilisation contre
la barbarie que constitue le para bellum
9 mm attention je vais maintenant
déclenché une émeute raciale comment
c'est simple regardez bien eh bien oui
vous avez compris pour bien mater une
émeutes raciales
il faut tirer sur les blancs avec une
balle à blanc et sur les noirs avec une
balle à noah a tellement
[Musique]
de nombreuses princesses là c'est de
livrer leurs corps d'albâtre aux
attouchements approximatif de tristes
dauphin dégénéré échangerait volontiers
leur prince charmant contre un plombier
charmant le plombier charmant est en
effet beaucoup plus virile
quoique légèrement plus salissant que le
prince charmant
lassé de livrer mon corps d'albâtre aux
attouchements approximatif dauphin
dégénère j'échangerais volontiers
chartrand plombier au couple quoique
légèrement plus salissant
mais direz vous comment faire pour
transformer une grenouille en plombier
charmant et bien c'est simple il suffit
de toucher la grenouille non pas avec
une baguette magique mais avec une clé
de douze magique
comment c'est simple regardez bien je
suis le plombier charmant c'est celle
plombier charmant
[Musique]
etonnant non
ne nous voilons plus la face la
troisième guerre mondiale est
inéluctable il ne nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps pour rigoler alors
dépêchons nous nous allons jouer à un
jeu très amusant
nous allons jouer le rébus vivant
regardez bien
cette semaine doit irrésistiblement vous
évoquez le titre d'une vieille chanson
française non bien
alors regardez voilà qui va vous aider
je suis le petit patapon
je suis un empereur romain très méchant
je garde les moutons eh bien oui vous
avez compris le titre de la chanson
était il était une bergère
il était une bergère iran iru petit
patapon
il était une bergère néron héron petit
il était une bergère qui garder ses
moutons d'entrants qui garder ses
moutons
etonnant non
[Musique]
afin d'inaugurer un poisson rouge avec
tout le faste et la seule la nit est
requise
il suffit d'avoir un poisson rouge une
ficelle une bouteille de champagne d'un
certain âge et une veuve de maréchal de
france millésime mai
[Applaudissements]
mais attention l'âge de la bouteille de
champagne et de la veuve de maréchal de
france sont moins importants que la
longueur de la ficelle c'est ce que je
dis toujours mon âge n'a aucune espèce
d'importance
ce qui compte c'est la longueur de la
ficelle en la longueur de la ficelle
c'est ça qui compte
pourquoi c'est simple regardez bien
[Musique]
etonnant non
le martyre c'est la seule façon de
devenir célèbre quand on n'a pas de
talent disait claudel ou marx ainsi
sainte blandine figure-t-elle
aujourd'hui encore en toute première
place au hit parade des martyrs célèbre
et on peut l'applaudir
chacun sait que blandine fut livrée aux
lions pour avoir dessiné des petites
croix sur les murs de rome or la jeune
chrétienne fut miraculeusement épargné
par le faux authentique mais
s'agissait-il bien d'un miracle eh bien
non
regardez bien
ben oui vous avez compris bourrés de
colorants sainte-blandine étaient
immangeables
etonnant non
[Musique]
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
obtenus par nos camarades par vos
camarades
après des années de lutte les
travailleurs les plus démunis vont
désormais pouvoir s'opérer eux mêmes
sans risquer de s'endormir pendant le
dépeçage
je m'attaque sandrine brouch à 28 tours
ne stresse 2002 à vierzon madame
sandrine brochard va maintenant réaliser
devant vous sur son visage grotesque
la première intervention d'auto
chirurgie esthétique comment c'est
simple regardez bien
grâce à l'abolition de l'anesthésique
qui ouvre aux travailleurs les portes de
l'auto chirurgie les pauvres aussi ont
droit à la beauté que belle que moi tu
meurs
etonnant non
[Musique]